so i think we should address some like
common concerns for people if they're
not familiar with the carnivore diet
although if they've been watching my
channel they probably are but for people
who say suffer from kidney disease or
heart disease
or high cholesterol do those people have
to be worried switching on to something
that's animal based no
next question no let me go into that a
little bit so no you don't and so
there's a huge myth in the medical
community which should not be
susceptible to mythology they should
focus and act only on facts only on
evidence but there's this huge
misconception in the medical community
that a diet
high in protein is bad for your kidneys
and i've actually done several youtube
videos about this explaining that this
is a complete note or myth
there's no research definitely no
controlled research that shows that a
high protein diet protein from any
source
is bad for the human kidneys and there's
definitely no
control research showing that protein
from meat is in any way bad for kidneys
and so
i've started using the
the phrase meat is good for your kidneys
prove me wrong show me the research and
until i've yet to have a single
controlled research studies thrown in my
face saying you're wrong big
meat is bad for your kidneys there is no
research that shows that yet the average
medical doctor dietitian nutritionist
they will especially someone with stage
one two or three chronic kidney disease
they will scare them to death oh you
need to avoid especially red meat
somehow red meat is magical
it's much much worse for your kidneys
than than you know white meat
but they're okay that's great so where's
the research oh then you hear the
crickets chirping because there is no
research that supports that whatsoever
which makes that
at best a hypothesis at worst a myth or
a big fat lie like i talk about in my
book
uh people with any medical condition
you're still a human being you're still
homo sapien sapien therefore you need to
eat a human specific diet a proper human
diet and for every human on the planet a
proper human diet consists of a large
percentage
of fatty meat and you ju
until we've got some controlled research
you can't even argue otherwise
what about heart disease yeah so heart
you know red meat is going to cause a
heart attack uh eating red meat is going
to raise your cholesterol so the
american heart association which is the
de facto world heart association because
most other countries take their walking
orders directly
from the american heart association when
it comes to all matters part related
they have stopped
a maximum amount of cholesterol intake
in the diets the research is very clear
and the reason why you didn't know that
michaela is because they they didn't
have a press conference as they should
have
they should have held press conference
conferences said we know we know we've
been recommending that you limit your
cholesterol intake
for decades but the research doesn't
support that and it doesn't matter at
all how much cholesterol you eat your
body is going to make the amount of
cholesterol you need so we are no longer
recommending that that's that would have
been the uh ethical thing for them to do
because what happens when they don't
hold that press conference is we even
though the top cardiologists and the
people that set the guidelines they've
stopped worrying about cholesterol
intake in your diet
and they've stopped recommending that to
their personal patients but we have this
thing that i call the echo of the lie
that i talk about in the book so even
though the preeminent authorities have
stopped talking about that they don't
even it's not even in there if you print
out their dietary guidelines it's not in
there anymore
but we still have all these doctors and
dietitians and nutritionists and mothers
and fathers who are saying oh only
cholesterol it's bad for your heart
that's it and it's idiotic
the because it was a it was a weak
hypothesis for a few decades and it's
been completely disproven even though
the researchers were trying desperately
to prove that it was a valid hypothesis
that he failed miserably
and we've still got this echo of the
light that your hairdresser will tell
you that your aunt betty will tell you
oh don't eat those the egg yolks it's
too high in cholesterol
but there's no research to support that
so
a lot of people listen to this will be
like you're telling me the american
heart association said that cholesterol
is no longer a molecule of concern when
it comes to dietary intake
yep it's on page 187 of their guidelines
buried in the minutia but it's there
and so then well okay well then what
about saturated fat eating saturated
fats badly yeah well they've also
stepped very quietly away from that
recommendation as well they don't really
speak about oh if you eat too much
saturated fat that is a direct directly
causative of heart disease no actually
that's no longer in their guidelines
either but again they didn't hold that
that press conference to let the world
know
so we've got all these people
who mean well right they mean very well
but they're just wrong
and uh you and
any smart person understands that no
matter how good your intentions are if
the information and teaching that you're
giving is just wrong you're going to do
harm and so there's all these people who
are scared to death of ancestrally
appropriate foods like egg yolks and
fatty meat because they're afraid it
will affect their heart because of the
cholesterol or the saturated fat
and the world authority on all things
heart related has stopped that
recommendation they don't even recommend
that you limit cholesterol intake or
limit saturated fat intake any longer
but they didn't have a press conference
so no one knows
what's that saying uh the road to hell
is paved with good intentions yeah in
this case i think that's very applicable
yeah no that's completely criminal in my
opinion i agree
at what point do we have a young
attorney out there who's hungry for a
class-action lawsuit or do we have an
assistant d.a in some state who's hungry
to make a name for herself and who files
a class-action lawsuit against one of
these organizations saying hey you're
actually doing harm
yeah by by not making public the fact
that you no longer recommend that people
limit cholesterol
and and saturated fat intake because
here's the harm that's being done
there are
all kinds of vitamins and minerals
essential fatty acids that you really
can only get from foods that are high in
cholesterol and high in saturated fat
and so if you're avoiding cholesterol
and saturated fat you're not getting
access
to this this this cornucopia of vitamins
and minerals and fatty acids that your
body absolutely needs
for essential optimal human function you
might be able to limp along without
these vitamins and minerals and fatty
acids but never will you realize your
best health your most optimal function
it's just not accessible to you because
you're being restricted from these
necessary nutrients
yeah i think a lot of people also have
been sick for so long that they don't
understand what it feels like to be
healthy absolutely agree it's it's human
nature to get used to where we're at
yeah right and i and so you see this on
both sides of the coin when somebody's
miserable every day
i didn't realize how good i could feel
without pain and rosacea and severe
heartburn and and dunlap do you know
what dunlap is michaela here in the
south it sounds it's horrifying it is
it's when your belly is done lapped over
your belt that's a southernism that we
say here and that means you're fat
i didn't i didn't realize how miserable
i was until i corrected all those things
but then on the flip side people like
you and i now that we've found our
point on the spectrum of a proper human
diet and we feel great every single day
we kind of get used to that as well
don't we and so
it felt amazing at the beginning but
then after 29 months of this it just
feels normal to me now to feel great and
to be able to go out and work on the
farm and sweat two gallons out you know
just non-stop manual labor that just
feels normal to me and so i don't i
don't you lose sight of just how bad or
how good you feel i think that's just
human nature
i think it's human nature too however
have you tried just doing like lion diet
style for six weeks super strict i have
not and i i i that is
to try i agree i have to try i agree
because
i feel great now but could i feel even
better exactly i know i totally get the
logic behind that and at some point i'll
i'll probably do three months because i
really feel like 90 days is what you
really need for any dietary experiment
to let your body have time to calm down
and to improve and at some point i will
do 90 days of just beef salt and water
and and just see
uh and you know i may have to include a
little lamb in that because lamb lamb i
eat mostly lamb very fond of lamb and i
like godot so i may just do 90 days of
rooming at me
yeah and i may do that here and i'll
i'll issue a you know a challenge to all
my people when the time comes
okay cool keep me posted i'll advertise
that on my instagram too so people can
join that's fun